l'école Victor Hugo aux clés sous-bois
renait doucement de ses cendres à la
rentrée prochaine les 194 élèves
pourront réintégrer les locaux
totalement reconstruits les travaux ont
démarré l'ouverture est prévue pour la
rentrée prochaine et cette ouverture
donc de l'école va de paire avec la
restructuration du quartier en avril
2010 un incendie avait ravagé l'école
primaire et suscité une vive émotion les
enfants avaient temporairement été
réunis dans des algéc sur le site de
l'école jeanorè pour cette
reconstruction la mairie a souhaité
mettre l'accent sur laapport de lumière
et notamment via la future bibliothèque
entièrement vitrée et tournée vers
l'extérieur la structure désormais
totalement désamiantée sera en bois et
en acier avec une isolation par
l'extérieur pour un aspect complètement
différent et moderne coût total de
l'opération 4 milli et demi d'euros la
renaissance de l'école primaire passe
également par la réhabilitation complète
du quartier de lavre une réhabilitation
qui a démarré la semaine dernière avec
l'inauguration du terrain de football
synthétique à terme le quartier verra la
création d'une air de jeu la réfelection
des abords de l'école la création des
parkings autour de la piscine ainsi que
l'aménagement de jardins
familiaux